CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman is
here good morning morning the defense
argument six minutes at the end what do
you make of their strategy well what
they had was a witness and only one
witness that they called for six minutes
and that witness was a detective who had
already testified for the prosecution
strategy is clear it's we don't need to
dignify this case with a response this
is a case built on reasonable doubt we
don't have to put on any independent
witnesses of our own we're going to
recall the government's witness a
detective to show what he left out and
what did he leave out well it's the fact
that Andrew constant and Bill Cosby
spent a little time at the Foxwoods
casino and that that really was to say
see they're not telling you the truth
they also asked to see his deposition
from 2005 that's where he could all the
pills that he gave Andrea constant his
friends and they they said they need to
see the whole context of that what does
that say to you what it says to me is
that there being a thorough good jury
that they are going through the evidence
piece by piece
if you have the first day of
deliberations they deliberated for hours
this is not a case of where they all say
let's take a straw vote and let's go
home what they're saying is let's go
through all of the evidence the way that
we should but that particular though
Ricky the fact that in particular we I
think what it tells us is this that
Andrea constant talked about that but
more important Bill Cosby corroborated
Andrew constants testimony by saying
that he was going to give her three
pills then he says that they were three
halves of Benadryl and that they were
her friends to relax her now one might
say well he really was there to relax
her and make her feel better about a
sexual encounter that was consensual or
was he really looking to drug her what
do you make of the Rick the makeup of
the jury because Cosby at one point said
that he thought race may have played a
role here what is the makeup of the
makeup of the jury is seven men and five
women and of those people you have one
african-american man one
african-american woman I think it's
always important to look at the whole
context jurors bring life experience
into the jury box in
deliberations so an older person versus
younger person a black person versus a
white person may have very different
life experiences how do we know that
look at the jury in a Jason the I know
you want to look at the closing
arguments for just a second and I really
want to talk about both briefly but the
defense closing argument we have to look
at what you got in Michael mcmoneagle is
an orator of supreme brilliance this is
a guy who literally shouted and he
whispered and what he let us know was he
used Camille Cosby to say hey he's a
philanderer but he's not a criminal and
shame on him right Ricky Kleeman thank
you very much we'll all be watching
today